so sind derzeit über 300.000 schüler
bundesweit im quarantäne
das sind aber natürlich das muss man
ganz klar zu sagen nicht 300.000
infizierte kinder auch nicht 200 oder
100.000 sondern nur ein bruchteil davon
ist wirklich corinna positiv und der
rest wird einfach als wäre das keine
schlimme sache als wäre das nichts groß
ist in quarantäne geschickt es werden
zum teil ganze klassen in quarantäne
geschickt und zwar für 14 tage und das
muss man wissen was das bedeutet dass
legt familien lahm
ja es kinder können wochenlang nicht
lernen für ihr für die fällt der
unterricht aus
und für eltern bedeutet das dass sie zu
hause bleiben müssen und ihre arbeit
nicht nachgehen können
und wenn man davon ausgeht dass das
jetzt ein jahr lang mindestens noch so
weitergeht weil kinder werden ja nicht
als erste geimpft dann können wir auch
den ganzen schulbetrieb dicht machen so
funktioniert das nicht deswegen muss man
die quarantäne verkürzen
es ist mittlerweile bekannt dass man
auch nicht zwei wochen lang ansteckend
ist sondern nur wenige tage
das heißt wenn es einen fall in der
schule gibt an einer schulklasse dann
sollte erstens nicht die ganze klasse in
quarantäne und die kinder die in
quarantäne müssen auch nur für einige
tage und dann sollte man sich davon auch
schnell frei testen können und da sollte
auch ein schnelltest genügen mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren